Hello. Welcome to today's episode of Rawkode Live.
I'm your host, Rawkode.
Today, we are taking a look at Promscale.
We're gonna learn all about that in just
a few minutes, but before we get started,
I do have a little bit of housekeeping.
So first, please subscribe to this YouTube channel
and click the bell. This is gonna get
you notifications for all future episodes of Rawkode
Live as we explore the vast cloud native
landscape together.
Also, if you like to chat, we have
a very active Discord server where we're talking
all things cloud native Kubernetes and everything in
between. So come and say hello. I look
forward to meeting you.
And one last thing, I just wanna thank
my employer Equinix Medal. They provide the resources
and time for me to invest in the
show so that we can all learn cloud
native together. So thank you very much. Thank
you very much Equinix metal. You can check
out Equinix metal was a code Rawkode
that will get you $200 and compute that
as around four hundred hours on a modest
instance. So check it out, have some fun
and let me know how you get on.
Alright. Now to guide me today on our
journey into Promscale, I am joined by Matt
and Vanneef from the Promscale and Timescale
teams. Hello there. How are you both?
Hey. How are you doing?
The the joys like of when you have
two guests on the show and then you
throw out the how are you question there's
always this like oh who's gonna go first?
So every time I do it I catch
myself but just a little bit too late
and I'm like oh, okay. Okay. So Matt,
hi. How are you? Welcome to the show.
Yeah. Thank you for having me David. I'm
doing well. Awesome. Do you wanna just tell
us who you are? What you do at
timescale?
Anything else you wanna share with us?
Yeah.
So I I've been at timescale
for
a long time,
pretty much since
timescale
was a company.
I used to develop the core database product,
And
about a year
ago, I moved on to
become the team lead for Promscale,
which we will tell you about today.
Awesome. Thank you. And, Vineeth, how are you
today?
Yeah.
Hello, everyone. My name is Vinith. So
thanks for having us, David. So it's really
a pleasure to join Rawkode.
And,
yeah, I work at timescale in the team
observability,
and my I primarily contribute to projects at
tops and from scale.
And it's been last seven months I've been
working with timescale, and previously, I worked with
other cloud native companies. And I also contributed
to Cortex and Open Policy Agent and Kubernetes
upstream previously.
So yeah. You keep yourself busy.
Yep. Yep.
Awesome. Well, thank you both so much for
taking time out of your days joining us
today and and hopefully, you know, we're gonna
take a look at Promscale today and a
little bit of TOBS. So why don't we
start with just a little bit of introduction.
I believe Matt, you've got your screen ready
for us here and you're just gonna
present a couple of slides. So please feel
free to take it away whenever you are
ready.
Yep.
So
hi everyone.
Most of this I already covered.
These are the ways you can kind of
get in touch with me on the Internet.
The other thing I was saying is if
you're interested in
any of the things I like to geek
out about, skiing theater, travel, or photography,
Just hit me up on one of the
Slack channels.
I'm always more than happy to chat,
especially in this pandemic world we live in.
And I will let Vinit also introduce
himself.
Yep. So yeah. Like, hi again, and my
name is Vinit, and I work as a
software engineer and Promscale team
and the observability team and timescale.
And feel free to reach out to me
to talk anything about cloud native open telemetry
or all, like, observability in general. So I'm
very active in CNC of Slack and TimescaleDB
community Slack. So you can reach out to
me at the rate we need. And feel
free to
mail me to beneaththattimescale.com
to discuss anything about tops, Promscale, or timescale
d b. And on my free time, I
just keep cycling, hiking, and reading books.
Like, if you want to discuss about anything
or even join me in India, just feel
free to reach out to me.
Great. So
let's start with what
Promiscale
is.
is an open source long term store for
Prometheus data,
which is built on top of TimescaleDB.
And TimescaleDB
itself is an extension to postgres SQL.
So this is a relational database
that stores
Prometheus
observability
data.
And what's unique about us is that we
store
all of this data in the relational database,
which allows you to use SQL analytics
to get much more insights
into
your
observability
data.
The basic architecture
is as follows.
Prometheus uses the remote right
and the remote read protocols
to speak to the Promscale connector.
The connector on ingestible
just
ingest data from Prometheus
and the write it to time scale DB,
which can be a single node installation
or
horizontally
scale, but there should be the installation.
And then you can install
you can use any kind of visualization or
analysis tools,
speaking either SQL
or PromQL
to to get data back out of the
store. If you are speaking PromQL,
you,
connect directly to the connector,
while if you are speaking SQL,
you speak directly
to the PromscaleDB
database.
But at this point,
you guys might be looking at me a
little bit side eyed because
traditionally,
relational databases
didn't
scale
for this kind of workload
because this workload
is very large. Right?
Preservability
can
ingest
billions of rows a day or
or even tens or hundreds of billions of
rows a day. But
time scale makes this possible because it allows
you to
scale your postgres
cluster to allow you to ingest
that kind of data volume.
In addition, it supports
column the time series compression
so that your data isn't huge on disk
and so that your budget doesn't explode. Right?
And so we use all of the
kind of best in class column compression
algorithms
including Gorilla and delta delta encoding,
etcetera.
In addition,
traditionally,
relational databases
can only scale up and not out.
But
timescale,
again, allows you to horizontally
scale out
your database
as it has a multi node version that
scales
kind of like you would any NoSQL database.
So
kind of maybe I told you a little
bit about
why this is possible,
but
why would you want to store your data
in Promscale?
Was it
or a couple of reasons.
First of all, unlike
most kind of for me, TS DataSource, we
support backfill,
which allows you to easily support
ingesting old data or
kind of migrating
all data into the system.
We support flexible
querying, as I mentioned before,
either in the PromQL
or SQL,
your choice.
We support the flexible ingest. You could use
the standard Prometheus
pull based model or you can push data
directly
to Promscale
itself.
It is easy to deploy and use, and
hopefully, the demo will kind of illustrate to
that. And we have
a lot of community support on our Slack
channel.
But and I didn't want to cover a
little bit about why
we're concentrating on Prometheus because I think some
people might not
be so familiar.
I think it's safe to say that Prometheus
is becoming the common data format
for metrics
in the industry.
And that's mainly because of its easy to
understand data layout. It's really
a time
series based
layout where you have a timestamp,
a
and a set of values
associated
with a tag set of key value pairs
describing your data.
And PromQL
has
really become at the standard in data reporting
queries today.
The other major
thing is it's cloud friendly. It's cloud native
to Kubernetes.
And
I think an important point to realize is
that the pool based model that
Prometheus
uses is
really good
when you have microservices
that
come and go
very quickly.
Combined
with
kind of a service discovery,
it really allows you to monitor
a
fast
paced cloud native environment.
And now
I'll look to beneath,
say a few words about
tabs, which is
the observability stack for Kubernetes.
Yep. So
Right. So, like, have another tool called TOPS,
which is the observability stack for Kubernetes. So
let's start why TOPS and what is it
all about. So deploying observability is way, way,
way harder in your Kubernetes cluster because you
already have your workloads running, and then you
want set up Prometheus and to put the
service discovery enable, like, what port what services
you want to scrape. And if it's Kubernetes
cluster, you need to run the cube state
metrics and all this. Like, you have so
many moving parts and so much of network
configuration,
observability level configuration,
and you need to configure like, if you're
using Promscale, you need to as a point,
the remote read and write in Prometheus to
Promscale and from Promscale to Timescale DB. So
any observability tool you install in Kubernetes cluster,
you need to configure it and make sure
that everything is working as expected.
So here comes the tops. So tops is
all about shipping observability stack in just one
command. And tops comes with all these components.
Like,
one interesting fact is that we just launched
tops, like, released tops, like, a couple of
hours back by switching the Prometheus and Grafana
help charts to keep Promscale. So we just
swapped out, and this is the first demo
we are doing post lot lot release.
And you are just looking at the latest
and greatest tops as of today. So, Alex,
just fingers crossed for that. And if you
look at into the components for queue Promscale,
so queue Promscale by default out of the
box comes with Promscale
alert manager, node exporter,
and Promscale operator to manage the Prometheus and
alert managers as a custom resource definitions.
And you have cube state metrics to it
it's something like it's an exporter for your
Kubernetes cluster.
So you get all the metrics out of
your API server. And we also install Promscale
and TimescaleDB for long term storage of metrics
coming from Prometheus, and we have PromLens.
Like, if you are building PromQL queries, so
it'll be just running.
Anytime you have any problems or questions with
the PromQL queries, just jump into PromLens and
build the queries.
Yeah. And why did we switch to cube
parameters? Because this is one of the biggest
and recent changes we have decided in the
last one month. And because
there's a lot of community and the community
acceptance for the cube Prometheus. So any user
we talk about Prometheus, they're already either using
Prometheus operator or they are using the cube
Prometheus.
And we have seen,
like,
heavy lifting already being managed by the Prometheus
operator and with the Q Prometheus tags. So
we wanted to switch to the Q Prometheus
because there's a higher a native high high
availability support for Prometheus and alert manager.
And also, offers Kubernetes mix sense, which is
out of the box alerts and dashboards for
your Kubernetes cluster.
So it's already pre baked for you. And
configuring Prometheus and alert manager as custom resources.
So every time you need to make changes
to your Prometheus cluster, there is no need
that you get into the Prometheus config, change
the alert manager endpoint, add alerting rules or
recording rules. You just put it in in
the form of custom resources, and Prometheus operator
will
reconcile it with the Prometheus for you. And
you have Prometheus operator for life cycle management
of the Prometheus, the config, and the alert
manager. So this is the main motivation for
us to
switch to the cube Prometheus from native Prometheus
and Grafana.
And this is the top's architecture as of
today. So post launch, like, so many components
have been changed. So I just put the
sketch as of today. And we have
the Kubernetes API server, which gets scraped by
the cube state metrics, and Prometheus scrapes the
cube state metrics. And you see all these
components
in your Kubernetes cluster. So you see this
dotted section
where the tops architecture comes. So once you
just do tops install, all these components gets
installed by default for you. So you get
all the observability for your Kubernetes cluster from
cube state metrics, and you get node level
metrics using the node exporter.
And you have alert manager to pop up
the alerts for you if by
default from the Kubernetes mix and alerts.
And you have Grafana
for to query the Promscale and Timescale DB.
So here, if you observe one interesting thing
is that the Grafana points to Promscale but
not Prometheus Because Promscale is the long term
storage
for Promscale, and Grafana directly by default adds
the data sources from scale for Promscale,
and you run all your Promscale queries to
Promscale. So Promscale takes care of
executing
the Promscale queries on top of Timescale DB
for you, and you just get all the
Promscale results by from the Promscale. And if
you are interested to use SQL for analytics
or for visualization within Grafana,
Like, you have timescale DB data source already
enabled for you in Grafana by default, and
you can run a scale queries from Grafana
on top of timescale DB. And apart from
this, if you have any other services running
in cluster, Prometheus by default has the additional
script configs enabled for you. And if you
have the annotations enabled for your services, parts,
and endpoints, the Prometheus by default scripts all
those services for you. So you do not
need to make any changes for that. So
this is the here top's architecture in high
level.
And so,
like, this this is something I always
I'm always excited to share about because
so if you talk about tops in general,
you have seen all those components. So if
you see tops has the two sections, like,
primarily, if you look at as a at
at a as a project. So one is
the helm chart. So all this packaging
of timescale d b, Promscale, Q Prometheus, all
this happens as a helm chart. So you
can directly install TOPS as a Helm chart,
and it's already available. And if you are
using TOPS CLA,
you'd not care about
what Helm and what are the changes happening
in Helm and how to
manage the full life cycle management of your
TOPS and your observability stack. So top CLA
offers you all that commands. So you just
run tops install, and all the architecture is
installed for you. And you have upgrade
upgrade to upgrade the tops from previous versions
to the new version, and you have all
the set of comments. And if you see
look at the sub commands also. So if
you have the final running and you want
to get the password in Kubernetes cluster in
the native way, you need to find what
secret it is mounted to, and and you
need to find the secret base 64 encoded
string and decode it and use it. So
it's always a long process to get the
passwords out of your Grafana or change the
password and everything. So tops just offers you
the comments like tops Grafana get password. It
just shares the password for you from Grafana.
Change password. It just updates the password for
you. And even if you do port forward,
it just load port forwards to your local
system so that it's easy for you
to manage and reach to the the Grafana.
Same with TimescaleDB.
Like, if you want to run the SQL
commands, you just run TimescaleDB
connect, and it just gets you to the
PSQL prompt of TimescaleDB,
and you can run all the SQL queries
then and there. And you have metrics. So
one interesting fact about the Promscale
long term storage for metrics is that you
can get the
retention policies per metric level. It's not like
it's not it's not global retention policies. You
can apply the global retention
policies also per parametric retention policies. You can
say that this metric is important to me
and have the retention policy for this particular
metric for sixty days and have the global
retention policy to thirty days. So all this
metric level
life cycle management also can be handled by
docs. And one other problem we keep noticing
with u observability stack operators is that volume
expansion.
So the more and more you start
scraping the targets on getting the data into
your long term storage, you need to expand
your persistent volumes. So you have this persistent
volume claims and everything for you. So there's
a top volume comment for you to expand,
And you have put forward comments for all
the important components
which the operator would like to interact with.
So you just do put forward for Promscale,
Prominence, Prometheus, anything just just port forward for
you. It's as simple as
running cubic deal port forward for you, but
tops does all that for you. It just
finds all the parts, the services, and it
does port forward for you. So this is
the top CLA what it offers for you
in high level.
Great.
Before
I kind of go into the Promscale vision,
David, do you want to kind of kick
off the install of tabs?
Because it might take a few minutes.
So we can come back to this after.
Of course. No worries.
So we have my screen share
up now. I'm looking at the Promscale repository,
but here's the Tobs one. Okay. So
in order to install Tobs,
will I just do the
the curl bash?
Yep. Yep. And
and we also have, you
know,
direct downloads from our
release page on GitHub because I know a
lot of people don't like curl bash,
But yeah, that's the easiest way to do
it. I'm happy to curl bash all day.
Don't worry about it. Okay. Yeah.
Alright. Yeah. Just move
it.
Yep. Alright.
And then it will oh, what
keep context will it use? Whatever I've currently
got?
Yeah.
Yep. Yep.
Yes. Fingers crossed. Like, you're just trying the
release which like, this it was released, like,
couple of hours back.
And we've already had one hotfix. So
Okay. So yours it says that failed to
pass. Can you just show me the Helm
version you are using?
Yeah. Yeah. Sure. So
oh, it's a Go app. Right? So
three five four.
Okay. It should be good. Like, it says
that parse helm show values from YAML to
JSON mapping are not allowed in this context
stream.
So Have you seen that before?
No. Like,
it's just passing the values. What
can we do for this is
Failed
to I mean, when and though try again.
Right?
Yeah. Yeah.
Failed
to post home
for values from YAML to JSON YAML.
Let's talk about what tops install is doing.
Alright?
It
is
installing
things from this chart repository? Yes.
This.
And then there's this values file that was
changed four hours ago.
Right. We suspect maybe there's a I bet
it's like a space or something in this
file.
Alright. Let's So.
I'm just gonna validate your YAML just in
case. Okay.
Great.
Vinit, could you,
kind of Google that error?
It's like I'm just able to I just
went into the code with it. I'm just
looking at so help show values. So what
we do before doing help ins help install
is that we do help show values,
and and we try to pass it to
Jason to analyze the data in the values.
So help show values as not
giving the results as expected is my understanding.
So can you just try to run help
show values for the release tops for the
help chat
tops so that
what's happening there.
Yeah. Of course. No worries. Let's just take
clone as repository.
Give that a Or the easiest way we
can do is that maybe you can just
point to these values and chat explicitly and
check does that work.
Show
values.
Oh, that's good.
Okay.
So
let's just run this
command, like, helm install
sorry, tabs install. Sorry. Yeah. Tabs install and
just point to the chart directory you have
locally just to understand, like, does it
make
So yep. I can see I can see
and I can see and chart.
I can see and point
it to the current working
directory. Yep.
And it's the same.
So
very strangely.
But maybe just you can just go with
the Promscale vision and after I'll try to
set up this environment and try to look
at the issue in the meantime.
Okay.
What do you think? Yeah. And and we
do have a backup
environment
in case
in case something like this
happened.
But yeah.
Okay.
Yeah. So let me just give a quick
overview
of
of kind of where we are going with
the Promscale
products in general.
We kind of think that the Promscale
should
be the
flexible
data storage format
for the observability
data. I should say data storage system.
So we want to support,
different,
architectures
in terms of pull and push.
We want to support different formats
in terms of remote write
JSON
text,
different query languages,
different
data ages, and by that, I mean, support
for backfill.
We want to support different
data types, not only floats
that are traditional for metrics,
but
shrinkers and symbols
that kind of,
are used by other systems.
You can think of Telegraph
or something else and even different data
modalities or signals.
Right now, we support metrics,
but we
hope to expand with traces,
loggers, and events as well.
But you might think why
why have all this less ability? Why, for
example, do you want to put all of
your sync signals
into one database?
Well,
databases are hard to run,
and it's this thing called state,
which is the bane of
a lot of our existence.
Say this hard. Right? You have to have
PVCs.
You have to have proper backups,
high availability,
failover.
In addition to just state, there's the regular
problems
of dealing with the security
with
scaling and tuning.
So
and the valid question is why deal with
this multiple times?
If you could have just one database
where you throw all your data into,
isn't that preferable?
In addition to kind of the ease of
use
story,
There's also
an advantage in terms of analyzing the data.
If you have all of your data in
a single database,
you could use joins between the different data
types to do
correlations
and more powerful analytics
and prediction.
So yeah.
We have some resources
for you here, but I'm sure we'll also
have that at the
bottom of the video or whatever.
Yeah. Yeah. I like those those things to
the show notes. Don't worry. We'll make sure
they're available to people. They can check them
out.
Yeah.
Russell,
DMS would be my
my
first guess as well. But I think
with
show values,
it's probably
one of those rare cases where it's not
DNS.
Well, that's the trouble with the live demo.
Right? You never know what to expect. But
Yeah.
So,
Vineeth,
do you have any
suggestions or should we just
share your screen
with access
to
to our
Kubernetes
environment?
Yep. So currently, I I am just removing
the existing top setup so that I can
start sharing the screen and install the setup
again and to show it. So just give
me a few seconds so it's just getting
deleted.
Of course. No problem. Okay.
I So can I ask a few questions?
Sure.
Alright. So your your slides have definitely
they set a really good scene about where
I think all of these things,
like connect together. So I just wanted to
make sure that my understanding of it was
correct. So
Promscale
is like,
I mean,
it's really just like a connector, I think
you called it, right? It allows you to
use
timescale DB
for the long term storage of Prometheus data.
So what you're saying is like, you are
aware
that Kubernetes exists and people are running Prometheus
and we've got open metrics and all of
these things that are just automatically
deployed. Like, you you highlight Prometheus,
which I think is a fantastic example
of just the community rallying together to get
metrics to be almost commoditized
within our Kubernetes.
And Promscale just allows you to drop that
into the cluster and take advantage and consume
those metrics, but while using TimescaleDB on the
backend.
And I thought that was, is really interesting.
Does that mean that Promscale,
it just has like
a limited time to left data? Is it
like three days, seven days and then everything
falls back to timescale DB?
Promiscule
itself is completely only a soft state. It
doesn't even save data
for
minutes.
It it actually
immediately puts the data into time scale to
be itself. Okay. So Promscale still runs in
the cluster and that's providing my
shorter term storage for things to be consumed
through the collectors which then oh, yeah. It
uses the remote rate and read API
to prompt. Yeah. Okay.
So is it is it you could think
of Promscale
as an alternative
to Cortex or Thanos or Victoria Metrics
or any of the other long term stores.
Yeah. And the way that
Prometheus works is the remote, right, and point
actually
pushes data out
not instantaneously,
but pretty close to instantaneously
as soon as the scripts it. So, like,
the latency between
Prometheus having the data and the data being
inside
of
Promscale,
TimescaleDB,
or however you want to think about it,
that latency
is usually less than a second.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. So when you mentioned
that I can send you know, an SQL
query
to from Grafana to timescale. That's just how
that works. Right? As we've covered timescale a
little bit in the past, I'm I'm pretty
happy with that now. Now is Promscale
is it just forwarding the query to the
local Prometheus or is it actually doing any
transpilation and then send it to timescale?
So
on the query side, the PromScale
does not
contact Prometheus
at all. It
it takes the PromQL query,
converts
it to a SQL query
that it then executes
on the database.
It gets the data. It does some post
processing,
namely
some of the functions
that PromQL provides,
we just reuse that
in the goal layer and the connector, if
you will, and then it returns
the results.
Fancy.
So
just a heads up here, David. Can you
just share screen? I just think I just
found the issue. Maybe we'll just give that
right. If not, I'll start sharing the screen
and write the demo. So can you just
get into the tops repository, like, the web
one web? So I I just wanted to
point you to an issue there. So there
is an issue already filed and we closed
it. So it's the cube config permission issue.
So can you give your cube config all
the permissions,
like, the seven seven seven or something like
that? So just change the cube config permissions
so that it's available for everyone.
So
so should I use my cube config or
your cube config? Yep. Your config. Yeah. Your
cube config. So whatever you have tried so
far. So I'm I just want to say
that change the file permissions.
So there is an issue with the file
permissions with helm.
So you just need to give the file
all root privileges.
So it's a it's absolute issue with helm,
and I just went through the closed issues
and tops and then
yeah. Just try to run Helm installments. Yes.
Just install here.
Let's see how does that work.
So it says the same?
Yeah. Yeah. It
is definitely 777
now. I'll just reset it one more time.
Dot q config.
At host install.
Yeah. I think it may be something different.
Strange.
So
so
okay. I I haven't
okay. I cannot okay. I just thought of
sharing you the issue which was opened upstream
and they just changed this cube config file
and it was just fixed. So I was
just thinking maybe that's the issue to
for this thing.
Mhmm.
Yeah.
So what's the cube config you sent me?
Is this a cluster where it may work?
Yeah. So I just want to install it
on my end because only the installation is
not working, but you can drive the demo
forward. So I'll just share the screen for
a couple of minutes to install and
set the things up. Yeah. Go for it.
So I'll just start sharing my screen. Yep.
I think you're able to see my screen
now.
Yep. Let me just pop that up.
Alright. We can see it.
Yeah.
So this is the Kubernetes cluster which I
have is in DigitalOcean, and it's in New
York region. So there will be a slight
latency issue. So just bear with me on
that.
I'm turning problems installed to the cluster. This
has the cube system components, nothing
else.
So it's just running the
prompt install.
By the way, like, if you want to
install Promscale and the TimescaleDB,
we are we do have our tops,
like, the Promscale help chart dedicatedly for you.
You can directly use the Promscale help chart,
and then you can just get started with
Promscale. So tops is something like you want
to get the complete absorbency stack, then you
can just get into tops. If not, you
just want Promscale with Timescale DB, you can
directly use the health chart of
Promscale and time scale DB.
So as it's getting started there, let's just
do get parts to understand what it's exactly
doing there.
So it says it's installing the observability stack.
In in the meantime,
actually,
David,
can you try on your machine
running
the and
passing it to
yamllint.com?
Okay. So what do want me to do?
Sorry. You want me to
The show values that we have before
that command
move it into p b copy.
Yep. Okay. So we wanna go to the
tops chart.
We run helm show values. We want a
p b copy to my buffer.
Oh, yeah. I've got a relative path on
my cube config.
So let's do Promscale.
Yep.
P b copy. And you want me to
drop this into a YAMLlinter?
Yeah. YAMLlinter.com.
It is
valid.
Valid? YAML.
Interesting.
Yeah. I have. I mean, could it be
my cluster?
I mean I don't think it's your cluster.
It might be like
I have a feeling it might be like
the
YAML library on your system, but I don't
know actually
how to
Should we upgrade helm just in case? I
have check that.
Maybe my helm's a little.
Let's see.
Of course now we have to wait on
brew which is not exactly fast. Yeah.
Let's see, do we have
upgrade?
And they always get confused before
between brew upgrade and brew update.
But yeah. Yeah. I think d five four
is the latest. So either the venture just
a bug in that version.
Yeah. You can't downgrade with brews. I think
I'm kinda stuck with this one.
We do have a question from
Russell if we wanna tackle that just now.
Russell is asking,
am I right in thinking that timescale DB
as a back end could live outside of
my Kubernetes cluster?
Yes.
Absolutely.
You can
actually, you can have both Promscale
and TimescaleDB
live outside your closet, but Promscale
can live either inside or outside.
So
it's
those two components,
you have some some flexibility
in.
Right.
Beneath, did you install,
Harish? Okay? Yep. Yep. So you're you're can
you just share
the screen for me, like Yeah. Of course.
Yeah. I'll put your screen up. Hold on.
Yep. There we go.
So
yes. So
one click, we just ran this tabs install
command and,
like, after a couple of minute, it just
gives you an output saying that happy observing
and what all good installed and how you
can manage for time scaling and problems. And
in the other tab, when I just took
the FPL gate ports, you have all the
all the stack installed for you.
So just to give
yep. So if you see here, we have
alert manager, Prometheus,
Grafana, and the Grafana DB to store all
this
extra dashboards and configurations metadata used for Grafana
and the timescale DB. So there's a job
to run it. And we have Prometheus operator
cube state metrics, and we do have Promscale
and timescale DB running here.
So this is the complete observability stack that
is offered by
the tops. They it just installed it. And
once you
stack has been installed, you can just do
Grafana and get password.
And you can just see the password for
the Grafana UI, and you do put forward
and just log in to the Grafana and
just start
performing the queries. So from here, I'll let
David take over the demo and drive it
forward for querying using SQL, prompt queue, and
everything. So, David, I just shared the queue
config file for you with you. So I
think you should be accessible you should be
able to access this cluster now.
Three cluster. I like it. Thanks. I'll keep
this one. Mhmm. Yep. Yeah.
Alright. I've got access to that. That's that's
so weird. I really hope it's not my
home version or something similar with that, let's
keep going. So you're saying I can run
tops
and you did
Grafana
get password.
Copy this.
And then you said I could just do
port forward. Right? Like this.
Yep.
Alright. So I can go to local host
setting. Already I love the top CLI as
like a helper just to get rid of
some of that really annoying
repetitive
get pods,
get labels port forward
etcetera.
Admin
password.
Alright.
What do we wanna look at first?
You might want to look at the kind
of the default dashboards
that are included.
The Cube Prometheus dashboards. Right? Yeah.
Do you have a favorite?
Let's look at it. Yeah.
One thing I just wanted to give a
try because
I do not want to give up on
running tops in your Kubernetes cluster. So I
just have a one comment. How can I
share it with you? Like, I just want
you to run that command, and let's just
give a final try. So do we have
a chat for weekend?
Or If you have your Slack open, my
CNCS Slack is there, or you can email
me. But, yeah, we don't have a Okay.
I'm in.
Okay. I am on the CNC of Slack.
I'm trying to okay. I'm just sending you
the message over there. So for a minute,
like, maybe you can run this command by
pointing your cube config file, and let's just
install a new cluster. So that's the last
try I just have. So this is one
fix I suggested in our Slack community over
long, long time ago, and he's he replied,
it just works. So I just want to
give it a try.
So
Yeah. Sure. Of course. Alright. So let's let's
just close this for a second.
Jump back over here. Close the port forward.
Let's see.
It's just spinning but it's coming.
Okay.
So,
shimod go dash r
and it's gonna be the cube config which
I have
here.
Yep.
So that's removing read access from group and
other.
Okay.
So let's try again.
Make sure I'm on the right cluster.
It's
working.
So
it's
it's a Helm bug that requires the file
to be six four four as you have
to read access
from
group and other.
So if you just can you open another
tab to list the parts? Yep. So it's
always the system related configurations,
David. Like, it's not the top. So I
usually run the top in our CI in
Linux, Mac, and every possible environment to test
our CLI. And it just passes there, and
when it comes to our users, like, users
just complain once in a while, and I
always see, okay. Oh, boy. It's your configurations
and all. So it's always there.
So do you see any new ports yet?
I think you see the new top sports
coming up. Yeah. I think you are good
to go with your own cluster, there's no
need of a back end cluster from my
end. Well,
good effort tracking than what has gotta be
a really infuriating bug.
I I I'm really if you had told
me the problem was gonna be
why does Helen care?
And why is there any message to do
with your Yeah. Doesn't make any sense to
me.
Hell, it's a great project. We all have
bugs in our software, but that one is
pretty special.
Okay.
You got kudos there from Russell.
Great work in getting the demo back on.
Are back on
my cluster
tops install has worked.
Everyone watching has now learned the hard way
that you must check the permissions on your
cube config otherwise helm will yell at you
and
we have already kind of checked,
so we think the things are running. I'm
gonna see if I can get my own
Grafana password there.
PB copy,
Port forward.
Maybe the pod change. Just make sure that
your pods are in running state. Just make
sure. Like, it just takes couple of minutes
to start up and all that. Might not
quite be ready yet.
Where's Grafana?
Yeah. Okay. Only one container's ready just now.
So we'll give that a few seconds.
Oh, there we go. No.
No.
Alright.
So
we've got access
to all of the
Prometheus
dashboards.
You also mentioned that installs PromLens.
That's the project from Julius Vulture. Right? The
the UI for Prometheus.
Yeah. And we
find that it's useful for
people getting started with
people getting started with the PromQL.
There's
I think PromQL
is a simple language, but there are a
lot of similarities
to it, and Promslens
does a great job of visually kind of
showing
what's going on.
Yeah. I'm a big fan of Promslens. I
think it's really interesting. Yeah. And I like
the way that it just kind of introduces
you to the language without it getting too
overwhelming as well. I'm I'm just gonna grab
some logs on this. I don't know what's
going on with our graph. So
Just do hyphen c Grafana. Yep. It's the
container Grafana, so you need to run hyphen
c Grafana to see the log. Yep.
So I think now it's running. So it
says you're able to take the logs. Right?
It contains Oh, there we go. Okay. So
the database just had completely jet, which is
just the job to set up.
Yeah. The least little things are sent to
test us. However,
we're gonna port forward now.
Look at that. There we go.
Make sure I got the right password.
So I think it's usually the trailing slashes.
This they get dependent sometimes. So it's the
common issue that this keeps in here.
And
so all these dashboards are from the Kubernetes
mix. And so we have dedicated dashboards from
the Proms Promscale team. So if you just
scroll down, you have something called Kubernetes hardware
monitoring and cluster monitoring that tag as this
Kubernetes.
So it is
it can it can yeah. These are the
blue one blue label. So you can just
open one of that dashboard. So it's like
an aggregated metrics to understand what is the
state of your cluster. So rest all Kubernetes
makes sense. Dashboards are dedicated to your stateful
sets, demon sets, and all that. So you
have different dashboards, and we we have plans,
and we have efforts to build more
dashboard for timescale DB, prompt scale, observability, and
all that. So you'll see more and more
dashboards and observability joining the family of tops
to get more insights into your cluster.
And all of these dashboards,
they are executing
PromQL queries
against PromScale
directly.
So this is not going through Prometheus
even though
some people,
do query Prometheus
instead,
but that
that kind of, has more latency because then
Prometheus needs to remote read to Promiscale,
which then needs to read from TimescaleDB.
So we recommend for people to reduce
one hop there and just
execute queries
directly against
Promscale.
And is that what Promscale is configured to
speak to?
Yes.
Yeah.
Promscale is also configured to Promscale, and you
can also show the data sources here. So
if you just
go to the data sources symbol, yep, you
can see, like, we have the Prometheus data
source. It is you see the Promscale endpoint
is being added there, and you have TimescaleDB
data source as well. So this, by default,
all the dashboards are powered up by the
Prometheus data source, but Promscale is the endpoint
there. So yep. And
I think we can get started with getting
started with Promscale doc for SQL queries. So
where you can see the beauty of Promscale
and Timescale DB and analytics you can get
out of our stack.
Alright.
Perfect.
So do you want to work through this?
Is that what you were saying there?
Yes.
I think Matt will
Yeah.
We kind of
we already kind of went through parts one,
two, three
because we installed.
And so
yeah. Let's go through part four.
Alright.
Let's see.
Yeah.
So before we do this, we just need
to update the time scale DB data source
with Postgres as the user because we have
Grafana DB as the user. So just get
into your like, can you open your CLI,
David? I just
can you just run talks timescale d b
get password to get the password of timescale
d b?
Yep. So,
yep, you just need to port forward the
graph on again and just copy the password.
So what like, we just released to us
back end. We were just we just found
one bug, a small bug, which is that
we just created a dedicated
user for
TimescaleDB
in Grafana, which is Grafana as the user,
but it doesn't has the admin permissions to
to
query the DB. So we are just updating
the user role in the TimescaleDB data source
so that the queries just work fine. So
you just need to the user should be
a post Chris, and in the password section,
you need to reset it to the password
which we copied. And
just test the connection.
Save and test. It's green. Yep.
Yep.
And
now we can just create a new
New dashboard.
Okay.
And
just add the data source as the timescale
DB.
And, yeah, usually, like, you have our beautiful
UI to just inject the values, but we
already copied. So you can also see the
all the metrics available from here here. But
can you just click on this
the edit icon you see here? Right? You
can just copy paste the complete query, which
we we have noticed from we which we
have seen from the docs. Yep.
Copy and then edit like yeah. And
you just need to paste it here. And
can you just take the visualization as table
in the right, the visualization?
In the right, you have at the right
section, panel section. In the panel, you have
visualization.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
And this selected table,
like, the sixth one.
Yep. And
you just need to get the data for
this and the table, but okay. You need
to add prom metric dot to the table.
So it's in the scheme of prom hyphen
metric.
So
prom Prom underscore underscore metric.
Yeah.
And then just click somewhere else. Like, the
enter doesn't work here, so it's the issue
with the Grafana UI. So you just need
to click on the outside of the query.
Yeah. It's not.
So
okay. You need to select
instead of time series and format it as
just select the table. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
There
we go. So yep. So we have the
data here.
Matt, I think you can just talk
just go ahead with all the other queries
we have in the doc. Like, each query
has a background and interesting story. Yeah.
Yeah. So
this is kind of allowing you to
query the data point.
It's a little bit isn't quite
that interesting. I will point out
that
we allow you to ingest
data both
via Prometheus and via direct push.
And when people ingest data via direct push,
sometimes the PromQL semantics
don't quite match
because PromQL
expects data to be regular.
And so this is one way where you
could just get the raw data for all
of your points directly.
But this is a simple
example just to give you a study, but
then if you go back to the tutorial,
there are more advanced
queries you could do.
So for this
is a good example,
actually, of an advanced query.
So So this is doing a percentile
Yeah. Which the
0.5%
of
oh, so okay. So it's trying to work
out what the 95 ninety fifth percentile is
of the duration of the goal runtime garbage
collection in seconds over the last
five minutes. Yeah.
This is kind of hard to see. It's
zero dot five. So this is actually the
median.
Oh, zero oh, yeah. Okay. Okay. Yeah.
So this is actually getting the median of
the duration.
And the one thing I I will point
out is that this is a query you
cannot do in PromQL.
Because in PromQL,
everything has to be done on a per
series basis
before you aggregate
it,
and
this is doing
kind of a global median.
And these kind of queries
are actually quite important
if you're doing things like
capacity planning
or deeper analysis of your system. For capacity
planning, you might
switch this.
David, as you already said from a zero
dot five to zero nine five,
but it's the same basic idea where you
want to get your global
kind of
percentile instead of
what the Promscale forces you to do, which
is a
double aggregation.
First, you aggregate
on the per series level and then you
aggregate globally,
which isn't quite the same thing statistically.
Nice. Okay.
So this is
kind of showing
already the value of
doing some
stuff in SQL.
Yeah. That that makes a lot of sense
to me.
Because I think, you
using
SQL SQL as a language that most people
have been familiar with for their entire careers
as well.
I know that people at
least I don't. I speak for myself only
here. I didn't enjoy learning PromQL.
In fact, I hated it. I really really
hated it. I worked for Influx Data, Influx
DB. I hated learning Flux and I still
hate writing Flux. You know, I've I've got
twenty years of knowledge of SQL in my
head that I wanna be able to use
for these kind of things. And I I
love where Promscale is fitting into this architecture
like, you know, like we said at the
start, you know, is now the de facto
way to get metrics out of a Kubernetes
cluster. I want access to those living dashboards
that are available,
but I don't particularly wanna use Prometheus for
my long term storage and be able to,
you know, just augment and then drop in
that timescale DB and prompt skill set in
the middle. I think it's a really interesting
architecture that just opens up
more possibilities
for people to have better observability longer term
as well. And something that I can't remember
who mentioned it, sorry now but you you
talked about push as well. Like yes, we've
got Promscale, we've got Prometheus doing the pool
within the cluster and writing using the remote
API to Promscale.
But I can push directly event driven or
events or traces right into timescale DB and
increase that observability
within all of my systems as well. And
I think that is a superpower.
That is this really really cool.
So Yeah.
What do what what should we take a
look at? Let's see or just pick one
or two more things that we can kind
of we can draw off. I think it's
really interesting to me that the Promscale does
query translation
to
to SQL. So maybe we could take a
look at that. But you saw the experts.
What what would you like to show?
No pressure.
Yeah.
Let's just just
let us see
which
actually, let me
see if there's any other queries
in that
in that tutorial
that we want to highlight.
It looks like the third query here, is
that
because I don't have the labels as JSON.
What's your JSONB function do?
Yeah. So this takes
the label and then the return of them
as as JSONB
objects.
So this is if you want to do,
like,
queries
using
per series analysis.
Right? You're getting now back
your
time series
values directly
along with the
labels that you are familiar with.
Nice.
Yeah.
I'm thinking what we can show you in
terms of the
translation.
Oh,
so
I think going
through the
the entire
transpilation
process
is is gonna be cumbersome,
but I do want to
point
people to a
to
our GitHub page.
And on our GitHub page
let me just make sure that there's a
link.
So if you go to the GitHub page,
there is a
There's a link to our design doc Oh,
yes. Which is Yeah.
Which is actually
a live public design doc that we had
hosted online
when we first started the project.
And this design doc
goes into the details
of
how we designed
the SQL schema
to actually store this kind of data.
And
it's it's pretty technical,
but the bottom line is that
we kind of have a very unique way
of
storing these label set
that allows a very efficient
kind of storage
mechanism
inside a
a
prompt q l.
Sorry.
Inside of a relational database.
And so
I think if people are really interested in
how we do this kind of
translation,
this is the the way to get that
information.
Alright. Awesome. I'll make sure that the design
doc here is also in the the show
notes. So if anyone does want some light
reading with their coffee tomorrow morning, this is
a good way to understand how it all
works. So Yeah. I think I'll enjoy reading
myself.
Yeah. I
was wondering if you had any any other
questions.
But just to give you a heads up
here in this so if you just scroll
down, we we have a bonus section. So
it's a very complex query. Like, if you're
you can just execute, but it just shows
you the power of SQL if you just
go deep down into the metrics. So this
is the big query, and you can see
like what it it has to offer for
you. You can just see That's script.
Alright. Let's copy. Let's copy it.
Let's see if I can guess where it
does then. I'll
let you correct me.
I mean
Okay.
Gonna select. It's got a meta max. It's
looking at container
memory limits
where there's a real value. Okay.
That makes sense.
Now it's then being passed into another select,
which is where No, I give up. Go
for it. What is it?
I can't juggle that much context in my
head at the same time there.
Assuming you're gonna pull out with the
statistical thing on how much container limits I
have on my cluster. I don't know.
So if you just scroll up, so there's
a small description in one line. It just
says that
so it just gives you the Kubernetes containers
that are over provisioned by finding those containers
whose 99 percentile memory utilization is low. So
this is one interesting way to understand how
your containers are over provisioned. So there is
a a big post by Dan Liu about
talking about a simple way to get more
values from metrics. So we just went through
that post and this query was built by
the
demon.
So you're telling me if I had just
scrolled up a little bit, I could've read
that verbatim and everyone would've thought I was
so smart.
And you like I think that's true. Looks
there's 30 lines of script SQL query madness
trying to work out what it was doing.
Thanks for me. Thank you. Anyway
But but by the way, I will say
that for
people watching, even if you learn
kind of nothing else from this talk,
go and look at that post by Dan
Liu. It really, I think,
the power
that you might
want to get from your
from your observability
data. And he really describes
kind of the
the real
business value
that search analysis
has in terms of saving people money.
Yeah. Okay. I will throw this into the
show notes as well. Lots for people to
read.
We have tomorrow's coffee.
And I ran that query. I updated the
from statements to sync with the prompt metric
and we can see here that we've got
all these containers that have some sort of
max memory allowed.
And we can see,
yeah, the percentile and all that.
Yeah. So How would you rate I'm assuming
I mean, you couldn't rate that in prompt
q l. Right? That just that just wouldn't
be possible. No. No.
Yeah.
Alright. Awesome. So the so I I guess
the point here is that
if
your percentile
used
is low,
you're probably over provisioning those containers.
You could do with provisioning them with less
data.
Yeah. That makes sense to me. Yeah.
Alright. We have a question from Russell.
Let's get that on the screen.
Russell also says, forgive me. I don't know
a lot about timescale, but can I use
all of the tools that I'm already familiar
with that already speak Postgres?
Yeah. This is
one of the beauties of the setup. You
absolutely
can
connect any tool that speaks postgres to this,
and you can use any of your available
postgres features
including, like
so time is gonna be as an extension
on top of Postgres. You can also install
other extensions. You can combine this with, for
example, geospatial data
using PostGIS.
All of the regular postgres
machinery
just works out of the box for you.
Awesome.
I can imagine that's quite a high value
selling point to people that are looking for
a database for time series data. Like, been
able to use
not just postgres, but you know, all the
tooling that they've been again comfortable with.
Very interesting. Yep. Tableau,
Power BI,
of these
things do work
with time scale.
Nice.
Yeah. Alright. Last chance. Maybe just another thing
to just just another thing. So we are
also working on building more analytic functions for
SQL. So what are the queries you are
seeing so big so they can be optimized
if you start using the analytic functions which
will be offered by timescale?
So already we are working and there's another
dedicated for project as timescale analytics.
So, yep, I just wanted to give a
heads up on that too. So you'll have
more SQL and more insights to your monitoring
data with the analytic functions.
Awesome.
I've got one other kind of random question
that's floating around my head. Just, you know,
you're saying that I can use all of
the postcard stuff. Know, I've been quite lucky
in my career. I've always I think exclusively
use postcards. I've never touched that
terrible one from Oracle. But they're like, you
know, I have access to views and triggers
and PLSQL.
Is all of that available to me with
timescale?
Yes. Yes.
Alright. I'm In
fact, a lot of
those features that you mentioned is how we
built
promise
a promise scale to begin with. The promise
scale is a collection of, you know, besides
all of the go code and go machinery,
it's sequence groups, sequence functions,
triggers,
etcetera.
So even we ourselves are using that underneath
the hood.
Alright. Awesome. Alright. I'll give you your last
chance. Is there anything else you wanna show
today before we finish up?
No. I would just encourage people to to
join our Slack channel and to
we're more than happy to answer any questions
that people might have.
Alright. Awesome.
Well,
I hope you've enjoyed having us look at
Promscale. It is a really cool way to
who can do the existing Prometheus ecosystem that
already has a whole bunch of value in
Kubernetes,
but have a Postgres based long term storage
for your metrics, which I think we've seen
through the sequel and the conversations today
offers
fantastic
benefits to you and your business.
Alright.
Matt and Vinith, thank you so much for
joining me today. I know we had a
couple of problems. I am not I'm I'm
probably gonna lose sleep over that helm thing.
It's gonna bother me so much.
But we got past it. We got everything
working and it was really cool to see
it. So thank you both for your time
today.
Thank you, David. Alright. Have a great day.
I'll see soon. Thanks for having us. Yep.
I'll see you all soon. Thanks. Bye. Bye
bye. Bye.